We're now going to talk about some interesting laws and regulations that you may have to
think about as a security professional from around the world.
We're going to start with some interesting, kind of more historical laws related to cryptography.
Then we're going to talk about something known as the Wasson Arrangements and then some
trans-border data flow laws or data residency laws.
But let's start here with this kind of historical footnote.
So here's a really interesting bit of historical trivia.
I'm going to take us back to sort of the late 70s, early 80s.
Back then, some amazing new cryptographic techniques and algorithms we're being developed.
It's like des the data encryption standard that we'll talk about.
And things like asymmetric cryptography, which would solve the symmetric key distribution
problem.
We'll get into all that later.
But these new cryptographic techniques were amazing.
And you could do some really incredible things with them.
You could encrypt information in such a way that no one, no one, could decrypt it.
And this was rather troubling to certain organizations, agencies, like the NSA.
The national security agency in the US.
And so certain laws were put in place.
So here is the fear, right?
Certain governments around the world were concerned that, hey, if someone were to encrypt
information with these new cryptographic techniques, we say the NSA would not be able to decrypt
it.
We don't have, they didn't have the technology to decrypt it.
And that was obviously very troubling to them, right?
Because they're job.
Well, for, you know, there's a lot of agencies around the world, not just the NSA.
And I should probably stop saying NSA because they're probably going to be able to find
me.
So the point is there are certain agencies, governments around the world that wanted
to restrict these cryptographic algorithms and make sure that they didn't get into sketchy
hands, like, I don't know, sketchy Canadians like me.
So certain laws were put in place to restrict the export of cryptographic algorithms.
And there's two of these laws that you need to know about, ITAR and EAR.
Here's the sort of simple thing you have to remember about them.
So ITAR stands for the International Traffic and Arms Regulations.
By the way, these are both US-centric regulations.
ITAR, here's the key thing I remember, focuses on defense-related items.
In other words, technology systems that are specifically meant for defense.
That's what ITAR focuses on.
And so certain cryptographic algorithms might fall under that category of only being used
by defense, and therefore they'd be covered by ITAR.
EAR, the export administration regulations, they cover what are called dual use items.
Dual use items are things, technologies, systems, night vision goggles.
Night vision goggles can be used by the military.
They can also be used by people in regular day lives, although I don't know why you're
wondering on night vision goggles.
But there are certain technologies that are used systems, technologies that are used
both by the military and by civilians.
And that's what are considered to be dual use items.
And EAR covers dual use items.
Simple way to remember this, ITAR covers defense stuff, EAR covers defense and everything
else.
It's kind of the way to think about it.
So these were really serious laws.
If you were found to be in violation of these laws, then you could be thrown in federal
prison.
It was pretty significant.
And these laws were expanded to cover cryptographic systems.
And so back in the kind of 80s, there was certain famous cryptographers that were actually
worried.
It was looking concerningly like they were going to end up in federal prison because they
were creating these algorithms and wanting to put them out in the world.
Now the reason these laws are still in place, but the reason they're not really applicable
anymore is that nowadays the absolute best algorithms that we use, like say the advanced
encryption standard, which we'll talk about later.
It's an open source algorithm.
Everyone has access to it around the world.
And in fact, that's why we trust it so much because it's an open source algorithm.
Most of the thousands of cryptographers around the world have all looked at AES, studied
it, and no one's found a significant vulnerability in it.
And that's why we trust it so much.
And so the best algorithms and encryption algorithms that we use nowadays are open source,
which is why these laws are not really applicable anymore.
They're not really enforced.
So it's a bit of a historical relic, but there you go.
You might come across ITAR or EAR on the exam.
Not super important topic.
One more not super important topic is something known as the wassinar arrangement.
This is a keyword here, voluntary regime.
So there's 42 signing members, 42 countries that got together, and they signed this arrangement.
And the whole point of this is that they are meant to exchange information, primarily related
to arms, weapons, things like that.
And the whole purpose is, as you can see here, wassinar aims to promote greater responsibility
among its members to, in exports of weapons and dole use goods, than to prevent destabilizing
communications.
So basically, these 42 signing members, these 42 countries, are exchanging information
about what sort of weapons and systems they're developing.
And they're trying to be open and transparent about this.
So there isn't concerns that, oh, this country might be building up a big stockpile over
here, but maybe they aren't, they're meant to share information.
Not super important, but it does sometimes the wassinar arrangement sometimes is mentioned
on the exam.
So now you know what it is, voluntary regime between 42 signing members.
Wassinar is a little town in the Netherlands, and it was in this little town in the Netherlands
that all of these 40, where the summit was, where these 42 delegations of these 42 countries
got together and signed this arrangement.
So that's why it's called the wassinar arrangement, not super important.
What we are going to talk about now is very important, and very pertinent to today's
world.
And these are what we're now going to talk about are trans-border, data flow, or data residency,
or data localization laws.
They have these different names.
They're all the same exact concept, which is these laws are designed to prevent the flow
of data across physical borders.
So for instance, I'm from the province of British Columbia.
There's a trans-border data flow law here in BC related to ensuring that BC residents
data, any resident on the government stores on BC residents remain on systems that are
in BC and not, say, transferred down and stored on servers south of us in the US.
Why?
Well, because the government here believes that they have a responsibility to protect
the citizens data.
And if that data was to be stored in systems and say the US, there may not be the same privacy
laws and regulations in place to protect that data.
And so, and this is one of the major reasons that all sorts of different countries around
the world are doing this.
The poster child of this is the European Union.
The European Union's overarching privacy directive, which is known as GDPR.
It has a very stringent data residency requirement in it, which basically states, if
anyone, any organization of any type collects data on European Union citizens, that data needs
to be stored on servers in a European Union member state.
And it's for the exact reason I just mentioned earlier, which is the European Union wants
to make sure that they are properly protecting their citizens data, making sure that the
right privacy controls are applied to that data.
And they can only do that if that data is stored on systems in the EU.
If that data was stored on systems and say the US, then I keep picking on the US here,
because the US is fairly well known to have not having the greatest privacy laws.
They also have this lovely thing called the Patriot Act, which I'm oversimplifying here,
but basically says, if any data trends at the US, even just passes through the US,
which a ton of internet traffic does, then that data is now the property of the US government.
They can do whatever they want with it.
It's not quite that severe, but it's that kind of idea.
So certain countries around the world have said, you know what?
We want to control where this data can be stored.
And we want that data to remain within our country's boundaries.
And that way we can make sure we have proper control of the data.
And so these trans-border data flow laws are often related to personal data, PII personally
identifiable information, but not always.
Certain countries, you know, like Russia, China, for instance, they have these trans-border
data flow laws, and they're trying to make sure that certain state information is not
leaving their physical borders.
So just remember this, trans-border data flow laws, and here's the other names, data residency,
data localization laws.
These are laws that require that data remain within certain physical boundaries.
And of course, the reason this is so pertinent nowadays is that everyone's moving their
data to the cloud.
And when you're storing your data in the cloud, where's the data?
I don't know, somewhere in the cloud.
It's very, very easy to fall a foul of these data residency laws if you're storing data
in the cloud, and you're not careful about exactly where you store it.
Now to be clear, the big cloud service providers, this is why they have data centers spread
around the planet.
They have data centers within the UEU, for instance.
So if you're collecting European citizens data, and you're storing it in the Amazon
cloud, you better make sure that you've configured your data storage location to be in data centers
that are in the EU, so that you can remain in compliance with these laws.
So that's trans-border data flow, data residency, data localization laws, ensuring that data
remains within certain physical boundaries.
It doesn't pass out outside of those boundaries to ensure the protection of the data.